奥劳拯救世界 让世界更精彩。
大家好欢迎大家来到胡刀刀 我是胡伟 我是一刀 我是熊二刀。
那我们聊了两期足球的话题 今天呢我们聊一聊和旅行有关的事。
具体呢就是随心飞这个产品又返场了。
反正也是莫名的返场了。
今天这个节目呢属于听有点菜。
因为在去年的时候我们免费的宣传了一下海航的666的随心飞产品。
还推荐给了不少的朋友。
那今年海航又出了一个66666。
后面我们大概把它简称为顺心卡或者叫五个六产品吧？
那所以就有听了去年666产品的朋友或者是买了666产品的朋友就喊着。
赶紧让一刀出来给大家做个分享。
你说这好巧不巧吧？
一刀前几天确实买了一张。
所以他可以出来跟大家分享一下心得。
除了这个以外呢？
还有一个就是一刀最近被倒刷的一个故事。
他是人在家中做
然后信用卡被倒刷。
所以把处理的过程也会给大家做个分享。
到时候呢我们会做个shownowns。
好久没有做过了
你们大家就暗需服用吧？
信用卡倒刷这个事其实我自己也发生过。
但是具体的细节我们就等一刀给大家分享吧？
因为马上也要暑假了嘛？
所以大家可能都有些出行计划。
我自己觉得了解起来做一个有备无患。
除了这些内容
一刀最近为了出油还弹了一个自己的酒店协议价。
这个也是惊到我了。
这种奇妙的经历介绍给大家。
看看大家是不是能暑假出行用得上。
行那我就先介绍一下。
海航的两个随心飞的产品嘛？
为了方便的话呢我把一个叫做660。
一个叫做666
这样大家听起来可能会容易记得。
那么其实两个产品的话呢？
客户的需求是不一样的。
有的人我知道不少人。
尤其好养毛的人是把两个产品都买了。
首先我们先看660。
660的话呢他这个660。
6块6的话呢是不归还的。
就是那个钱就相当于买了个权益。
然后每次买票呢还要再花199块。
只能是早晚航班
而且屏蔽了寒暑假和很多假期。
非常的适合这种特种兵的旅行。
另外就是早起晚睡的人也很适合。
但是呢他有一点啊除了屏蔽这节假日以外。
还有就是热门航线要抢。
比如说深圳到呼伦贝尔就是秒空的。
这个产品我们就不具体展开了。
我会把84期的节目链接放在评论区。
大家可以去回听一下。
我对我过去一年的666做一个总结。
就是我还是飞了10趟。
感觉还是回本了的。
肯定回本的很多
飞一趟的回本了我飞了14趟。
汪飞一次深圳到那个。
呼和浩特感觉就回本了。
那我们就进入今天的这个重点。
66000呗
对那66000也叫顺新卡。
它其实顺新卡还翻三款产品。
就是根据年限来分。
就是你一年两年三年。
拿我们最常买的一年来说吧？
它其实就是你存66000。
一年到海航这里
一年之后这66000其实是退还给你的。
只是你没有利息
那么在这一年的话。
海航会送给你大概是。
8张免费的机票
这8张免费的机票。
是可以用于全国的。
就是海航集团下
全中国的11家航空公司的。
任何一个国内的航线。
任何时间段 任何日期。
只要这个航班还有经济舱的票。
即使是全价的经济舱的票。
也都可以买
另外就是韩价 暑价 春节。
只要有票都可以买。
我这做个补充啊？
我们这期节目是纯自发做的。
没有任何海航的广告植入。
那这里边我也提示一下风险。
虽然一刀说
这是没有利息的
当然大家可以把这8张免费机票。
理解成为这66666存在海航的利息。
那还是那句话
只要是花钱 只要是有投资。
都是有风险
所以务必提醒一下大家。
好了 那我们接着让一刀讲。
那就是超过8张票之后。
怎么办呢？
超过8张票之后
你可以按照每张票。
379元的价格购买。
但是这个价格只能给自己买。
你不能给亲友买
如果是给亲友买的话。
就是按原价了
但是这个每张379。
是可以从你那个66000里面扣吗？
它是可以从的66000里面扣。
但是我们建议不要从的扣。
因为会涉及到
它后续的一些积分送之类的东西。
会其实更复杂一些。
就是你最好是用自己的钱去买。
或者用它积分买
这是养猫档给的建议。
这里就带出来了一个。
666和666的区别。
666的机票呢？
只要你能抢到的话。
只有199
但是它是有时间限制的。
刚才我们已经强调过了。
但是这个379虽然贵。
但是它是没有弹忘记的限制。
这是一个非常重要的区别。
这也是为什么？
一刀会买的一个原因。
一会会讲到
对
一般情况下
这个票是不用抢的。
除非是这个经济商真的卖完了。
否则你都能买到
但是呢？
为了避免大家去拼命的去。
就预留着票嘛？
所以它也有一些方法。
比如说
其中有一个方法就是。
666的顺行卡在忘记的时候。
只能提前7天定票。
也就是说春运的时候。
节前的7天
节后的4天
51的节前2天
节后1天
和11的节前3天。
和节后的1天
那么你只能提前7天买票。
是不能提前
比如说半年之内
就去抢那个
去订那些票的
因为这些时间比较特殊。
但其实我们看那个时间。
在全年放的全年来说。
是比较短的一个时间的。
其他时间
即使是暑假
也是可以提前
很多天去购买的
其实说白了就是那个。
特别大忘的时候
人家不缺那个买家。
所以这个时候最好。
你不要来买
然后像那些弹机
大把的票你就随便去买吧？
多卖一点
试一点
是的
那666其实是可以。
提前7天免费退票的。
也就是说在你出发之前的。
7天包含当天
你想退的话
都可以随时的退
这个666它可以吗？
666其实是不能免费退改签的。
就是不能免费的
主动的退改签的
为什么呢？
因为666的时候。
它其实是你最多
只能订3张票
是没有费的
没有费的只有3段里程。
那也就意味着限制了。
但是666的话
是没有限制的
你可以订无数张
它就很怕有的人就是无聊。
或者说为了抢占
我就先把所有的票都订完。
会导致你所有的机票都没了。
是吧？
所以它话
666你无论是改退签。
主动的改退签
都是要扣钱的
只是扣的也不算多。
比方说
如果是提前7天以上的。
退改签的话
变更费是38块
也就大概是10%。
而退票费是76块。
大概是20%
随着这个时间的不断临近。
那么它收费的标准。
就会越来越高
比方说
如果到了4小时以内。
起飞前4小时以内的话。
变更费就到227块。
而退票费就到303块。
扣的不算多
但是也是一个警示作用。
告诉你
不要随便乱订票
那如果是No Show呢？
No Show就是你订了。
但是你没有去做
也不做任何退票什么之类的话。
No Show3次的话。
才会很严重
它会冻结卡的权益30天。
而且
如果是多次的话
它会把你扣掉
航班的全价的票款。
不是379元是真正的全价票。
这也是一个警示作用吧？
避免有的人
就是订了票不去做。
就是刚才你说
666是没有利息的。
然后牛又说
它其实相当于一个。
利息产品
这个到底是为什么呢？
对 这个还挺有意思。
还有我们刚才讲的。
这个8张机票是怎么来的。
其实是这样的
那么？
你买了666的顺行卡之后。
其实它是送了你3333g分。
这3333g分
相当于是3333块钱。
那么你定的
这379元的机票费。
就可以用这个机分抵扣。
所以算下来
为什么说大概是
8张的机票
就是这样
用3333除以这379。
所以大家这么算一下。
你想3333
大概是66666的4.99%。
大家可以理解为
这是一个将近5%的理财产品。
大家现在都知道
现在定期就跟没有利息一样。
这几乎是这个
一年定期的5倍
甚至还多一点
我们都讲过了 对吧？
这个只要是定期
这个一倍以上的
这都是高风险理财产品。
这个更高
所以我务必提醒大家。
到目前为止
我跟熊东还没有买过。
只有一刀买了
对 其实这个是有风险的。
而且海航以前
曾经破产过
会变成新海航
所以大家注意
当你购买的时候
一定要仔细考虑清楚。
自己能不能承担风险。
我开玩笑说
好像新海航也没有几年。
难道明年之后就新新海航了。
所以我们现在有很多群。
顺心卡之后有很多群。
大家说也好
现在是抱团考虑怎么耗羊毛。
要争倒了
大家就会抱团一起去拉横幅。
那我们都说了有风险的话。
买了之后能退吗？
这个是可以退的
我们等等就讲
有一个方法是可以退的。
另外积分
我还要额外再提醒大家一下。
这个积分可以抵扣机票以外。
它甚至连机场的建设费。
和燃油税
都是可以用这3333积分抵扣的。
所以是非常的划算的。
也就是说其实
如果你的飞行次数不够8次的话。
你也可以飞个6次。
然后拿3333去抵一些。
燃油机件也都可以。
飞行次数不是那么多的话。
也是用
没错
那我们总体来看
这张卡其实非常的适合。
函鼠架还有节架出行的人。
就是该熊也说了
随心出行的人
想飞就飞
今天我就想去乎伦贝。
放个养的
那我们看到有朋友的话。
鼠架从深圳去新疆。
它往返就要6000块钱。
而另外一个朋友的话。
买了这个66000顺新卡。
直接用积分兑换
所以他就一下子
就感觉赚到了6000块钱。
我今天早上有那么一瞬间。
确实有一点点心动。
因为这几天
零支半成马拉松开始报名了。
我先去看了一下机票。
我现在发现北京
零支的直飞往返
大概要1万多块钱。
这个很明显了
因为经济上已经卖完了。
中转的航班都要超过5000块。
但我发现海航
其实可以玩一个飞行旗。
我可以先飞到重庆。
然后重庆中转过去。
如果我买了这个产品的话。
其实就是379x12就能搞定。
所以我那一瞬间真的是。
有点心动
但是我始终在提醒自己。
我得注意风险
你还忘了提醒自己。
你要先种一个
零支马拉松的签才行。
因为这个票是不能退的。
改签要付费的
刚才不是讲了
这就几十块钱的退票费。
我这个我还是付得起的。
我们再来讲讲这个。
如果想退卡怎么办。
刚才的纽约说了
就是如果真想要退卡怎么办。
如果你是比如说买了一年期的产品。
然后你要提前退
那这时候要扣你13%的金额。
也就8600多块。
这还挺贵的
当然有一个方法
如果你拉了三个新人。
买了这个66000的顺新卡之后。
你就可以不用交这8600块钱的。
违约费了
就可以退掉它
听到这里之后
我觉得可能又有听友会来问你们健群。
为什么不是有听友说。
你们是传销组织吗？
听起来
像要拉心一样是吧？
没有群真的没有群。
也没有收到海航的广告费。
这里呼唤一下
有朋友认识海航的人。
赶紧跟海航的Marketing团队说一声。
这有三个自来水
一直在宣传他们家的产品。
我想了一个好方法。
直接把那个一刀的那个邀请码。
发到 show notes里面。
我已经拉够了
拉扣了三人了
现在那么如果
你要注意拉够三个人之后。
是可以退卡的
不用交这8600的违约金。
但是有一点小小要注意。
它其实最后退的话。
是退你63333块。
扣下你33333块钱。
但是给你留了33333的基分。
这数字满天
不知道听什么朋友们。
听的运不远
也就是说
它其实只是说
给你退的时候
如果你成功的拉三个人。
给你退钱的时候
只退了63000。
然后还有3000的话。
是转成基分给你
而不是退成钱给你。
我们把这个规则到时候。
贴在show notes里。
大家去看吧？
另外为了鼓励你发展新的用户。
你每拉三个新的用户的话。
海航还会给你奖励3000多基分。
那么这3000多基分。
是海航顺行卡的基分。
就类似于等同于3000多块钱。
这也是一种
激励你去发展下线的手段吧？
这里额外要提一句。
我们该讲的海航顺行卡的这些基分。
其实跟我们平时讲的。
航空里程基分是不一样的。
海航顺行卡里面的这些基分。
其实就等同于钱
一基分就等于一块钱。
而平时那些里程基分的话。
是靠你乘坐飞机
一点一点的累积起来的。
那个没那么值钱的。
那个大概可能是10到30基分。
才大概等于一块钱。
听说最近这个基分。
也可以交易了
对大家说
这3300基分用来做什么？
基分现在其实是有很大的用处的。
现在已经可以
转卖了也可以交易了。
甚至在咸鱼上还有人收。
以930的方式收。
因为有很多人其实是。
可能飞得很多的
比如说我经常会看到。
群友们说
就是顺行卡的群友们说。
就是可怜可怜两地分居的情侣们。
他就是9折和930。
收分
那如果我没有顺行卡。
我可以收这个分吗？
你可以收这个分
但是没有用
因为你收了这个分之后。
你不能以379块买这个机票。
我必须要有一张顺行卡才行。
对
你没有顺行卡
好像他
我们之前有人推卡说。
顺行他那个分
会转到一个叫海航钱包里面。
那讲一下实际操作部分吧？
你为什么会买一张顺行卡。
我买顺行卡的最主要的原因。
是因为我没有给我妈妈。
抢到深圳到互伦贝尔的。
199的机票
然后呢？
如果在协生上买的话。
单乘要1500多块。
从哈滨中转的话呢？
单乘也要1000块左右。
也总不能让老人家。
这么辛苦的自己去中转。
和各种费吧？
算了一下说
算了
既然我妈把钱存在这个。
活气上
这个利息那么低
还不如把它买了个顺行卡。
然后利省3000块。
于是就买了
我一直都说
我们这帮人都是
典型的省小钱
花大钱
是吧？
为了省3000块。
然后存了个
66666的海航产品。
然后还要打上
孝顺母亲的这个
好处
但是我听说
母后这一趟
因为用了这个顺行卡。
好像感觉还挺满意的。
是吧？
听说服务还不错
对 非常的满意
我也听到了
一刀是怎么？
会用我们寒腰去买。
他说
你那么多钱
存那么低的一个利息。
或者买这些
那些不靠谱的产品。
理财产品
还不如买一个顺行卡。
对 然后小腰
已经买了
首先我告诉他
顺行卡的
第一个好处就是
可以抢占第一排
这个是小腰的最爱。
因为第一排的话呢？
一般都是被预留
给高卡用户
因为他可以伸直脚。
所以的话呢？
很多这种高卡用户。
就是必争第一排
但是其实我觉得
做的第一排的问题。
是你每次
先上去做了
都被无数人的注释一把。
这个也是母后
比较happy的一点。
对吧 他不用再
走好远
他一进去他就可以坐下了。
对 而且立刻有人问候。
所以的话呢？
还是挺好的
如果是海南航空
自己的航班
因为海航集团
底下还有十几个
这个航空公司
如果是海南航空
HU的话呢？
那你可以直接
线上就可以锁定第一排了。
只要没有人给你抢。
手速足够快
那就可以直接锁定了。
而普通的用户
油管锁这个第一排的座位。
我们试过
是要花2000g分的。
我们知道5000g分。
都可以对一个
深圳飞三亚的机票了。
所以应该不会有人。
花这个钱的
这顿时也显示出
这个还是挺划算的。
所以小腰
听到这个之后呢？
已经立刻买了
而且其实
顺心卡的好处
并不只是
我们刚才说的
就是一个理财产品。
它其实还有一些
附加的权益是吗？
对
它其实的话呢？
会送你一个
类似金卡的权益
可以进贵宾厅
但是第一年的话呢？
是个准金卡
你买的是一年的产品。
第一年只能是个准金卡。
它只能进海航
自己的贵宾厅
大概是有
九个自营的贵宾厅吧？
像北京是有的
北京上海都有
但深圳没有
很可惜
后续的话呢？
一年之后呢？
它会送你一个
真正的金卡
真正的金卡的话呢？
我们就知道
那时候你就可以用。
它所有的贵宾厅了。
几乎每个大城市都有。
很多城市都有
另外的话呢？
还可以带一个人进入。
额外带一个
同行的人进入贵宾厅。
所以还是非常的方便。
当我发现
这一招其实也挺狠的。
就是因为
第一年就算
给你一个
准金卡
你也挺乐意的
第二年
如果你不去费
你看看
还有给你一个
真正的金卡
如果两个航空公司。
比如海航和某航
它价格差不多
但是你有金卡
你会选择谁
肯定是选择海航
是吧？
所以就相当于
第二年给你一个
真正金卡
是吸引住你
留住你
希望你第二年
再续卡
或者至少你既然不续卡。
在买航班的时候呢？
优先选择海航
这个我觉得市场
营销人做得也挺好的。
对我对我来说
这个金卡的权益
是可能更吸引人一点。
因为
我们都在国外
经历过就是
那个要check in的时候。
通常要排
一个小时左右的队。
但是如果你有这个权益的话。
你就可以走那个
头等舱或者公共舱的通道。
这个就是完全可以。
节省你一个小时的。
在机场的排队时间。
而且呢？
当年还是
海航银卡的时候
就是
就可以带一个同行者。
甚至于
我觉得海航是比较好的。
它不会像某航一样说。
你只能带一个人
或者你不能带人
它会一看
哦 您有两位同行的。
那我就给您两位
fast pass。
然后再给您一位
休息室的权益
所以它相对来说
就在国外的时候
是非常非常有用的。
还有一个就是
如果你再要带行李的话。
这个额外行李也很重要。
就是你要买
很多东西
或者你要带去国外。
很多东西的时候
这个额外30公斤的行李。
是一个很重磅的东西。
尤其是当我扛了
一箱啤酒回来的时候。
对
这个其实还挺好用的。
海航
其实国内的五星航空。
可惜它没有找我们多广告。
白给它做了这么多广告。
没有付钱给我们
那我们看到就是
即使你在第一年
你的顺行卡
头等舱和公务舱
的柜台办理直击的。
而且很多机场都是有。
专门的快速安检通道的。
比如说深圳
我们已经试过了是可以的。
而且登机也是优先的。
刚才讲了
熊也讲了
有额外的一件行李。
额外还有30公斤的行李。
那么其实有点好处就是。
当你做连航的时候。
这个额外的30公斤行李。
就非常重要了
是免费的
像这种快速安检通道。
提前登机
是另外一个让母后。
特别happy的点。
而且还有一种
带你出去旅行的那种。
感觉
所以这个情绪价值还是可以的。
但我必须说
其实它还有一些隐藏的权益。
然后可能大家
没有遇到的时候都想不到。
好巧不巧呢？
一刀就出行了一次。
就把这权益给解锁了。
对 没错
就是当你遇到
航班取消的时候
顺新卡会给你公务舱的待遇。
这点还挺重要的
它会给你一个
人均400块的住宿费。
这是我们遇到了
就是我们刚好遇到了。
航班取消之后
只能因为当晚就没有航班了。
就第二天才飞
那我们第二天才飞之后。
就是我们就可以定一个。
在兰州机场附近的。
皇冠假日的酒店的套房。
其实你是可以自己选择的。
因为我们刚好是三个人。
所以的话相当于每个400块。
就已经有1200块钱的这个额度了。
是可以选择很多很多酒店。
我们直接定了这个皇冠假日套房。
而且发现还没有用完这个额度。
其实还是挺可惜的。
而且还有一个可以解锁的。
就是这个其实是和666的时候。
是一样的
如果遇上了航班取消或者改签。
你可以把航班改成一个。
你更想要的航班
例如666的时候。
那个不是早晚航班吗？
你就可以改成一个时间很合适的。
不是太早不是太晚的航班。
而还有一点就是
你可以改目的地城市。
本来你要从一个
你要飞到一个
不是特别好的城市去中转的。
你现在可以直接改到。
你想要飞的那个城市。
是这样吧？
对没错
你是可以改到
临近的城市的
比如说我们这次
本来是从西安飞回。
深圳的
然后的话
因为我们是在青海玩。
后来发现取消之后。
我们就改到了
从兰州飞
那么从兰州飞的话。
我们从西陵过去
就快很多
就一个小时的火车。
所以大家都很开心。
所以大家如果遇到航班取消。
或者是变更的时候。
海航是可以
顺新卡还有666的话。
都可以改一个
临近的城市的
这一点还是挺人性的。
那你日常耗羊毛的。
这个调性的话
你可能还要再搭配。
一个航班盐物
或者取消险
然后再顺便再多耗一下。
对 原来有
但是现在好像已经。
没有那么容易耗了。
原来的靠普飞
普发的靠普飞
是非常好的
可以搭配着用
请那个信用卡公司。
再继续推出
类似的活动吧？
我们可以再耗一把。
那我的问题就来了。
因为我是一个有666的人。
我有了666之后。
还需要买666吗？
或者是两个
为什么需要都同时持有。
你这个问题很好
是有可能买的
而且很多人都买
首先我们看一下
660的话
它的成本是更低的。
它每飞一次
只要199块 是吧？
只不过它只能
早晚航班飞
那么有不少航班
比如说深圳
深圳其实飞呼伦贝尔。
本来就是一个早上的航班。
所以的话
如果你有666
你又有666
那么如果你能
抢到票的话
你当然是用
6006的是更好的。
因为紫花199块。
就能飞了
所以你把
更有用的
留到那个级分
666的级分留到。
6006没有的航线。
会更好
所以很多人
就同时都买
因为6006的
每次单次飞行成本更低。
而且你们这次
是不是买的票
是用的666的
权益买的票
但是当航班取消理赔的时候。
是给你按公务舱待遇。
也是按照你顺心卡的待遇。
给你理赔的
对
因为当你买了
666的顺心卡之后。
从这个时间
你就变成一个高级用户了。
那么不管你在这一年期间。
你是用什么方式买的票。
你是用199块买的票。
还是怎么样
级分兑换的票
你都能享受高级用户的待遇。
和高级用户的
比如说问候
净贵并定等等
都可以
我必须说
作为一个用户
能解锁这些技巧
都是个挺难的事
所以我不知道
海航产品经理
设计的时候
掉了多少根头发
这点好像还真的
有点打动我了
这是第二个打动我的点。
我感觉这录节目
是你俩在给我挖坑吗？
不 我也没在坑里。
那推荐你们俩
去入韩小洋的坑
他还有车尾
等待的拉你们两个新人呢？
我们要入一刀的坑。
因为要拉横幅一起了。
那我其实还有问题。
因为
刚才我们说
非不够八次的话
是不是值得买
我刚才说
也许我非六次
然后用那个
其他的积分底
但是是不是
如果飞行次数很少的话。
这个
也没有太大的优势呢？
因为很多用户
他不是长旅客
他不是经常飞行的。
那还要值得买
这么一张卡吗？
如果飞得非常少的话。
而且或者是你飞得比较近。
其实
就看你怎么想
也可以不买
因为我们知道
有很多很近的航班。
它其实
票价也不贵
但是呢？
其实它还有个好处。
就是这个积分
刚才讲的积分是可以。
最换的
你可以把这个钱
类似于卖掉
要换钱
或者这样说吧？
如果你买了
海航的孙心卡
每年只飞个一两次。
飞得非常少的话
那你其实买它
就相当于买一个
5%的理财产品
但是呢？
因为其实是
拿的是海航的信誉。
去背书
再考虑到
它以前是破产过一次的。
所以我觉得
这个不太划算
或者说是有
一定的风险吧？
大家自我把握好了。
如果让我说的话
就千万别碰
这个让自己的生活简单一点。
以我飞了溜溜的感觉。
就是一旦你拥有了。
这个身份之后
没有条件
也要创造条件飞
对 你看
这样一分析下来
你们俩
就性格都很鲜明了。
是吧？
牛是绝对
如果我要骗你的话。
也不嫌打你电话
因为你好难说动
那我们真的不是给海航。
打网告
所以海航讲了这么多。
大家的问题
应该都有设计到了。
如果还真的有没有。
设计到你的运用场景的话。
你也可以给我们留意。
然后我们再来研究一下。
对
我们最近因为
把各种方式都试了一遍。
各种问题都遇到了。
所以有时候
比他们的客服
还要更专业
好 那我们说完了。
这个顺新卡的产品。
在进入到下一趴之前。
我还是要提醒大家。
这其中是有风险的。
不要只是看好的一面。
那我们就聊一聊
信用卡这个事吧？
这个其实也挺意外的。
因为有一天
上午吧？
其实没有到一刀
平常起床的时间
结果他突然就在群里面。
都开始冒泡了
说自己的信用卡
被倒刷了
而且倒刷了
很多比金额还有点大。
然后告诉我跟许荣说。
他已经处理完了
所以一刀
跟我们分享一下
处理的过程
和一些自己的经验。
好的
那我其实的话呢？
是前几天的早上
当我醒来的时候
我突然发现有两个。
未接的电话
那两个未接电话
是某某银行打过来的。
我心中就知道坏了。
因为我睡觉的时候。
都会把那个调成静音。
毕竟现在也不会有。
什么人在凌晨的时候。
给我打电话
结果就没有接到
然后我迅速的点开。
短信一看
果真有两笔巨款
被刷了
是在凌晨4点40分的时候。
于是我第一件事情。
要做的就是迅速的。
给某某银行的客服。
打电话了
然后我迅速告诉他。
被倒刷
迅速接通之后
客服就告诉我
现在急着要做两件事。
第一件就证明你的卡。
在你的身边
那怎么证明呢？
就是你拿你的这个卡。
去到你最近的ATM。
去做一些操作
比如说取款
或者是查询
实际上这个时候
我的卡已经被冻结了。
因为我被倒刷了几笔之后。
系统就发现有风险。
就把我的卡冻结了。
但不用管
你去那做
只是纯粹的是
为了让你有这么个动作。
让系统记录
这卡其实在你身边的。
而不是在
不是丢失的
这样方便你后来
后面就是
把这个款拒收
或者是退回来
另外的话
大家去查卡进去查询。
或者取款
取款之后
它一般会有个频条。
以防万一这个频条。
大家也最好是拿着。
先拍个照
保存你要拿着
这第一件事情
证明卡在你身边
去任意一个银行的ATM。
然后去做一个操作。
取款或者查询都可以。
但是取不出
或者查不了的
没关系
只要有这个动作就可以了。
然后有频条
把它收起来
第二件事情的话
那么打邀约报警了之后。
它其实就记录你
有出警号
然后你有报警的回职。
这个回职的话
也很重要
你要拿到
而且保存下来
有的时候还要拍照上传。
我当时打了邀约之后。
邀约就把我记录了。
然后的话
会告诉我
去最近的派出所
去找警察叔叔
然后取到回职
一切都挺顺利的
当然我发现
我去了警察那边之后。
我顺便
把这个案例也给大家。
讲解了一半
另外还告诉了他们一个。
很重要很重要的东西。
就是大家也可以注意。
就是怎么样
怎么样才能让你的。
不会发生这种的凌晨。
被倒刷呢？
就是大家要把你的。
卡的境外交易
给关闭掉
我原来还没有注意到。
其实大部分的卡
你的银行卡
即使你是国内的
都已经默认开通了。
境外的交易
包括无卡交易
和这种刷卡交易都有。
那我会把这两个都关了。
还有的银行的话
其实还挺好的
它还可以
把晚间交易也关了。
就是你可以把晚上关了。
更有些银行的话
还可以设置你的
常用的国外地区
就比如说我经常
比如说我经常去新加坡。
是吧？
那我可以把新加坡打开。
就是它可以在新加坡的。
新加坡可以刷卡
无卡交易
但是其他的国家是。
不能刷卡和无卡交易的。
这个还挺贴心的
有的银行
甚至还有就是
你点了解锁
就是临时30分钟。
可以给你30分钟刷卡。
刷30分钟之后
就自动锁定
大家可以在
很多银行都可以在。
APP上直接
自己进行这个操作。
如果不行的话
你可以打电话
到银行客服
让他们帮你把
关闭掉
这个大家一定要注意。
因为很有可能
就会避免
像我这样
被境外倒刷
那小小的总结一下。
就是如果发生了这个事。
也别着急
对吧？
先跟那个信用卡的。
公司沟通
然后证明卡在身边。
怎么证明呢？
实际上就是在
ATM上做个操作。
或者做个查账
另外就是打110报警。
拿报警回职
交给信用卡公司之后。
我自己的经验
其实一般都还是
能有妥善的处理
然后另外
其实就是
要不为了安全起限。
你把所有的
境外交易都关闭
或者是
根据这个国家
做个选择
另外我自己觉得
你当时的建议
还挺好
但是我还没有来得及。
问我的信用卡
公司能不能做这个。
就是可以选择性的。
把中国业建交易的。
选项关闭掉
我觉得这个还蛮好。
因为大部分的
倒刷实际上都是
咱们的业力
以我的经验
就是这套流程
是一个标准流程
而且非常的成熟
所以你不用担心
你的那个钱
就被划走了
最后的这笔交易
是不被认可的
所以不会划账给他的。
所以我们跟一刀说了。
就是
事情发生了
不要慌
现在的节目
那
一刀的
最近的羊毛
也真是惊到了我们。
所以
不只上面讲的这些。
昨天他又跟我们说了。
一个特别牛的事情。
让我惊掉了下巴
对
我自己签了一个
酒店的协议价
一刀的
专属的酒店的协议价。
比某层某租便宜
而且还多了几份早餐。
我之前的话
去
西北的一些地方
不具体点名了
然后就发现
有些连锁酒店
其实我发现
到前台问一下
好像价格还挺便宜的。
所以这次
我不是要去内蒙吗？
去互论贝尔
我就提前打了个电话。
到我那个新仪酒店问了一下。
结果发现
嗯
他还真的可以便宜些。
但是他们告诉我说。
你要跟我们签一个协议价。
我一听
还要签协议价
没错
你只要有营业执照。
发过去给他
然后的话
不用你是法人
然后他们就会有一套流程。
搞下来
然后我发现
总体来说
还是比很多OTT便宜的。
我们已经对比过了。
几乎是最便宜的
所以我给一刀了一个任务说。
你去把这些
连锁酒店都给我签一轮。
或者说当地的
你去过的好的给我签一轮。
然后之后我们去的时候。
就直接用你这个协议价。
就可以了
你的这个协议价是。
就是你要去的
互论贝尔的那个
酒店 only
还是说全国的
我现在还不知道
现在他好像是
因为他是这个酒店。
是一个大集团的
所以的话
但是在他的这个酒店。
应该是有个
特别特别低的协议价。
给我专属的
然后其他的话
也比市面上一般便宜。
不妨你试一试
我把这个协议价
那我倒是就跟着你混吧？
我觉得
这个下边的留言
一定是
有群吗？
可以用协议价吗？
要我把这个协议价。
这次住了之后
然后我再拿他去
别的地方再住一下。
然后看看再谈一下。
如果能谈下来的话。
我要搞一个
胡刀刀专有的酒店协议价。
给你们最划算的
这个FLAG已经立好了。
我的天哪
我感觉这就是为什么？
你现在不上班了
比上班还要忙的一个原因。
行 那我们今天就聊到这吧？
然后有更多的羊毛。
或者是有更多的这种。
小tips之类的。
我们还会在后续
给大家更新的
画牢拯救世界
让世界更精彩
海航快来打钱
海航过来投广告
这期一定有修诺词了吧？
否则这不得有了
刻代表才行
有争取
这期争取把它
不是AI写的是人写的。
我已经很长时间
都在修诺词里贴了。
这期没有修诺词
我已经懒得说
我以前还会写一个。
一刀又出去玩了
所以没有修诺词
我现在都是写的
这期没有修诺词
这一刀下周出去之前。
赶紧把修诺词写出来。